breaking just moments ago former new
york governor andrew cuomo has been
ordered to give up the five million
dollars that he made for his book about
his response and his incredible
leadership during the kova 19 pandemic
so he thought investigators say that
state government staffers helped work on
the book cuomo claims that they were
volunteering on their own time and he is
vowing to fight to keep the cash fox
news senior meteorologist janice dean
joins us now by phone she lost her
husband's parents in a nursing home an
assisted living center in new york after
the former governor said that facilities
could not reject patients because they
had tested positive for covet and she
has really led a long fight to bring
light to that issue and it is one of the
major factors that led to where governor
cuomo is now which is that he's no
longer governor uh jan it's good to have
you on the phone um your reaction when
you saw this story break just a short
time ago
well it's about time right martha i mean
i i think jay cope have tried to vote on
this for you know many sessions and
they've many times said no need to keep
the book money uh the 5.2 million
dollars but now they've finally found
their conscience and say that he has to
return all the money and it just goes to
show you that this ban has so much power
over these people for so long that i
believe they were scared to tell them to
return the money months ago uh you know
i think the book deal was the thing that
was finally his undoing this time last
year he had the emmy award uh the the
book deal was in full swing he was doing
interviews on every single major channel
uh and and this time last year i thought
to myself my voice is not loud enough
you know i was ready to give up because
this man was so revered
so to finally see some justice that he
has to give the money back and
by the way martha i mean if you look at
the timeline
of when he started
making plans to write this book
that's when he started to lie about the
nursing home numbers so he was actively
covering covering them up
i think that was really a huge part of
his undoing
if if it became the case that he was you
know sort of coding things for the book
um and not being transparent about the
numbers on the other side i think that
was a huge turning point for him and you
um really pushed to shed light on this
story all the way through of course his
attorney says there's no way he's going
to give back the money uh and uh that
they will see them in court so this is
not going to be over um they gave him 30
days we'll see where it goes janice
thank you thanks for calling in great to
talk to you as always
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis